[Music]
everybody welcome to Planet Costa
College in this video I'll be talking
about the arrow hypercoaster and showing
you how to build one and in a sense it's
a bit of a sequel to the arrow looping
cursor tutorial since much like the
arrow looping coaster this is really a
classic kind of ride it's a bit outdated
it's a bit old compared to some of the
newer hyper coasters out there but
that's kind of the charm of it as well
and what I want to start off this video
with is actually the definition of a
hyper coaster because this is quite a
contested area because there are many
ways to define one I would say there are
generally three ways to define them
though the basic two ways are basically
by height and the type of coaster so to
take the first one height of the coaster
a coaster is regarded as a hyper coaster
usually when it exceeds 200 feet in
height which is 60 point 96 meters so
everybody just kind of disregard Stan
and uses feet here anyway which is based
of the first hyper coaster that was ever
built magnum excel 200 not to be
confused with the magnum excel which is
a hyper coaster by arrow it was the
first hyper coaster to ever be built and
the tallest coaster when it was built
and it's also very good example for this
kind of coaster now the problem with
calling a coaster a hyper coaster just
because it's taller than 200 feet is
that after that time especially recently
a lot of courses have been built that
exceed 200 feet but aren't generally
seen as hyper coasters but sort of
chucked into that area anyway because
they're over 200 feet high so another
way to define hyper courses then is by
the type of layout hyper coasters have a
very specific kind of layout which looks
almost like a wooden coaster they don't
have any inversions they usually aren't
very compact but instead they have very
tall lift Hills that are followed by
very large Hills that give you a sort of
wooden coaster skyline and at some point
managed to come back with some sweeping
curves I have some more hills and make
their way back to the station so they're
not very compact they don't have any
inversions and it's just focused on the
hills the airtime and making your way
through the curves ad and as fast as
possible speed
since they were usually the record
breakers when it comes to the height now
of course another way to refer to hyper
coasters especially in game is by the
train design because they do have a
different train design usually than
other types of roller coasters since
they don't have to worry about making
any inversions and instead you want to
make use of that air time and these
large pills that they have so they have
different trains and that's something to
keep in mind in game to always take the
actual hyper coaster trains if you want
to make a hyper coaster generally I
would say in game if you want to try to
make a realistic hyper coaster you want
to go for all three of these points so
you won't actually use the right type of
coaster you want to get over the 200
feet in height and you want to make sure
that it has that typical hybrid coaster
layout so how do we do so well that's
something that I'm going to show right
now so we're going to take the equalizer
right here and place the station as per
usual a little bit raised of the ground
and again since this is an arrow cursor
kind of like the arrow looping coaster
I'm not going to worry too much about
making this thing smooth and instead
it'll be a bunch of different pre-made
elements all just paste it together
almost in a roller coaster tycoon kind
of sense so first just to get a bit of
speed I want to get a small hill that
goes down like this could even be a
little bit more than that honestly it
could be quite steep just make that a
little bit more smooth but I'm not going
to worry too much about how smooth it
actually is something like that should
just about do and in this case I just
want to add a curve on to the lift or
doesn't always have to be a 90 degree
curve or anything just a small pre lift
Hill section before it hooks onto the
chain and at this point we can pretty
much get to the chain itself and as per
usual also I want to make this about 30
degrees the transition into the changes
that have to be to smooth it can be
pretty jagged and sudden so I'm just
going for something like this and the
most important points to keep in mind
here is that we're building this over 60
points 96 metres in height or for
anybody who is using the imperial system
anything that's over 200 feet and in
this case since it's it's quite an oldie
I just want to break the record of 200
feet maybe build it a little bit taller
than the coast to be
for its but then a sign I don't want to
make it too tall so I'm going for
something around this height just a
little bit over 200 feet now something
that I always find very interesting
about these when it comes to the drop is
that they actually have a very awkward
looking drop it doesn't go down in a
very straight kind of section it
actually goes down very gently in a
sense and I suspect though I wanna I
don't want to claim anything without
actually researching this I couldn't
find anything about this but I'm pretty
sure that this is due to the cable
stress and releasing the car at a lower
speed being better for the cable and not
putting too much stress on the cable but
in any case we want to go for a small
pre drop section actually hole once we
hold on to the cable for a little bit
over here we want to have a small pre
drop section which is still quite gentle
something like that and only after we
have that sort of gentle parts we want
to go down into the very steep and a
good section of the drop so when I go
down to something like this and we have
a lot of straight rank over here which
is not going to end up very smooth but I
actually don't want to smooth that out
because just like a regular old arrow
hypercoaster would this is pretty much
just some transitions of the lower parts
and the top parts of the hills with some
very straight sections in between for
what the hills actually go up and go
down with so I'm going to curve it right
here to go up again and go into the
second hill but once we're actually
going into the second Hill I just want
to keep it 100% straight now this is
really the classic hyper Hill which is
quite steep and has a very gentle bottom
of the hill on a very gentle top of the
hill just fast enough to catch some air
time on it because that's really on the
top of the hills where we're going to
want to catch a lot of that you want to
make it just a bit smoother than that
and something like that should more or
less be the shaping for the coast it's
already starting to get that sort of
wooden coaster look to it in terms of
the skyline now at this point you can
add another hill or more or whatever
you're looking for but there's got to be
that point on
Hyper where you want to turn around now
there are various ways in which they
usually do this if they have this kind
of classic sort of out and back layout
to them
for instance magnum excel has a sort of
butterfly looking element to it and
Pepsi Max just does a curve to turn
around but in this case I can want to
try a bit more and show a bit more about
the weird and unsmooth banking that
these things usually have so I'm going
to go up again for a bit to go into the
hill which is going to be the first hill
before we go into the elements where
it's going to curve around I want to
make sure that each Hill is going to be
just a bit lower than the hill just
before it's so I can actually make this
quite a bit lower and stretch it out a
bit something like this and what I want
to keep in mind is that I want to bank
the track before we actually go down so
I'm going to have a part where it's
going to go down a little bit here or
sorry I want to bank the track before I
go into the curve so I'm going to have
part where it's going to bank right here
and after that it seems like a pretty
safe place to add the curve so let's try
it something like that should work I do
want to stretch this out quite a bit
actually that's quite steep still for a
curve of one of these coasters I can
make that a little bit less steep and
just go around like this and this part
is interesting because we're going to
get back into the station at this point
and this is where I kind of want to show
off the very standard a roller coaster
tycoon kind of way to make heroes with
these coasters what you very often see
with these coasters is really just hills
that are built like this going straight
up and then we're gonna have these very
gentle parts where we go up and down and
transition back into a knob section may
be a little bit more smooth than that
but you get the points basically these
do not flow very smoothly whatsoever and
especially on the hills in the later
sections of their tracks where they've
already lost a lot of speed and they're
just making their way through some of
the final airtime Hills which are much
smaller they really are very unsmooth
and the shapes like this
are definitely not a rare sight on the
East Coasters I do feel it's starting to
fly over my hills at a too large speed
so I can you want to add some trim
brakes over here to slow down the rest
of the coast Ribbit's and keep the hills
in the lower in the later section a bit
lower I'm not sure but it kind of seems
like the friction settings on this
cursory is actually quite low in real
life some of them do lose their speed
quite a bit and I think Magnum XL 200
now is quite a few trims on it as well
but anyway in my case it kind of seems
like the layout is going to flow better
with a couple of trim rakes so I'll just
be adding a few over here now we're
getting to the end of the track here
where usually it just finishes up the
track with a bunch of very small airtime
Hills a bit like what I've been doing
over here even though in this case I
would say it's a bit more exaggerated
than what you see with most of these in
real life there are only five toes out I
wouldn't really hold on to that idea too
much but some of them do have a bit more
turning around action so by the time
that the track is next to the lift so
again as I have over here the hills are
much smaller but I still have quite a
bit of energy to burn through since the
parts with the curve over here is
actually quite small and it already goes
into the smaller Hills over here so I
think I'll be ending of this track with
a few more curves into the direction of
the station and just ending it up like
that and again with these curves they
are very unsmooth just like the hills
over here so first it's starting to bank
then it has the curve and then it's
going to Bank straight back into a
straight piece and I'm going to want to
do just about the same over here with
these curves I do want to draw them out
a little bit as well because otherwise
it's just going to be painfully unsmooth
but this piece is just completely
inclined and then this piece is going to
go gentle again and the next piece is
going to go down again which sounds all
weird but it's just like you kind of
like doing one thing at a time as you're
taking the pieces so either you're
banking or you're really changing the
direction of the curve but you don't see
both happening at the same time all the
time now since we're almost there again
I want to start at the end of the
station to have a slightly inclining
break run and usually since these are
you
enormous coasters they want to store
another train as well so they do have a
transfer track along with a bunch of
brakes to not just bring down the cursor
to a lower speed into the station but
also have some block brakes to train
another or to store another train on I'm
going to want to have a pretty lengthy
good block section over here so I'm
going to have the well regular now I'm
going to have the block brakes over here
first at the end and there's also going
to be some brakes to slow down the
coaster and possibly have a brake
section on the side here just all the
coasters on the transfer track if they
need to so that's pretty much why I want
to have at the end and at this point I
can just connect it back to where I want
the coaster to go in ventually so here's
the final layout of the coaster and I'm
very serious when I say this isn't
really one of my best not too proud of
how it turned out but it's definitely
got all of the basic elements that
you're going to want to have in a narrow
hyper coaster out there so we have the
large lift hill right here which is by
far the largest structure on the coaster
some of these very sweeping large Hills
at the beginning section of the coaster
some very long curves in the middle
section which you do see quite often and
some of these typical much smaller not
so smooth hills at the ending section of
the coaster to still make the most out
of the very limited speed that it has at
the end of the layouts and altogether
it's got a very out-and-back almost sort
of wooden coaster layouts to it there
are definitely a bunch of variations on
this actually switched up this Coast
because I didn't want to make it too
much like the existing Aero coasters but
ways in which you could have some
variations on this theme is by either
making this section with the hills a bit
longer or maybe having a section with
much more curves that twist in and out
of each other I think Titan in Japan is
a very good example of that or having
much more of these very small hills at
the end for instance I feel like magnum
XL just keeps on going on with these
very small hills at the end of the
layout where it makes its way back to
the station anyway this is just the
basic template and there are many ways
to have some variety on this but just
for the ending of this episode and when
I have a
PRV alright so here we go it's still
going very slowly because the cables on
these things aren't the most quick
things and the first drop is actually
quite steep it's also very loud for me
whoops uh hum and the second Hill is
just about fast enough to catch a little
bit of airtime on top of that I am quite
happy with the general speed of this
coaster it does go a little bit slow at
some points especially the trim brakes
could be trimming a little bit less
given the speed at which is going
through this curve but it's not
something that I would say is something
to really worry about at this point it
still has a very manageable speed
throughout the rest of the layouts and
we're coming back to some of these
smaller Hills at the end where there's a
bit of awkward curving in here but
generally you want these things to just
be completely straight it's very simple
and boring track when it comes to that a
bit of a curve to make it way its way
back to the station and I only made this
final sort of out and back section
because I still had a lot of speed but
if you don't you can really just make
your way back to the station with a
quick curve as long as you do have
enough space at the end behind the
station to actually have the brake run
which we're finally heading into at this
point and that is pretty much the
coaster there are a couple of things
that you might want to change about this
when it comes to the color scheme the
red color I suppose is actually taken
out of Pepsi Max big one I know that
some of the developers actually pretty
fond of that coaster so that's probably
where the color scheme came from but
many of these coasters also just have a
well not many but make them excel which
is the classical one has a red and white
colour scheme which also works quite
well if you actually select the white
colour whoops there we go something like
that could work quite well as well or I
actually like Titans color scheme quite
a bit too which is yellow with black
which turns out quite interesting it's
actually a bit more gold in this case I
might want to make that a little bit
lighter there's just many ways to have
some variety in these color schemes but
what I would want to say is that usually
the the real-life ones don't have to
interesting or too bright color schemes
not like many modern benhams would have
they are quite boring and predictable
color schemes in a sense anyway that
just about rounds it up for this video
about arrow hyper coasters it's not
really the best one ever but it's really
just a general idea of how you can make
one of these and I wanted to close this
video with another look at how we could
look in a real-life setting you really
do want to bring out the skyline of
these things as much as you can like
wherever they are placed they were
really placed in such a way that you can
see them and be like whoa that is really
one heck of a tall coaster since they
really were some record breakers back in
the day nowadays they're sort of
neglected and nobody at Cedar Point
really goes to magnum XL 200 anymore
well some people definitely do but
they're not really the most popular
rides anymore and they're overshadowed
by many courses that have been built in
much more recent years but there's still
a very classic staple of rollercoasters
despite only a few being builds and
there are still many kinds of very
modern hybrids being built which are
still sort of legacy of the old Aero
Hyper's which I'll talk about in some
later videos but this is really all I
have to say about this one so I hope you
guys enjoyed this video and learn
something from it and if you have any
feedback or questions don't be afraid to
leave it in the comment section below
and I'll see you guys in the next video